c'est la mère la mère total et dans un
chantier on a perdu déjà quelqu'un qui
s'est blessé tout à l'heure mais bon on
fait avec on n'a pas beaucoup de moyens
c'est le feu partout le matin après midi
tout en cite une vraie cata c'est c'est
des gros bouts et on se fait chier c'est
hyper sérieux
j'ai envie de pleurer est nul à chier
j'ai pas des numéros d'urgence à
ma connaissance mais si quelqu'un peut
me sortir de là
[Musique]
salut les gens derrière l'écran vous
êtes sur le making of de la websérie qui
est sortis normalement il ya quelques
temps je sais pas exactement combien de
temps ça fait qu'elle est sortie mais
bref on vous montre l'envers du décor
ici on s'est installé dans une grange
pour faire un décor un petit peu sympa
il ya plein de gens qui sont venus
donner un coup de main et ça c'est
génial de bosser en équipe ça a été
quelque chose de super cool donc on va
où ils vont vous parler un petit peu
tout au long de cette vidéo
mais il ya marie qui était chez fo qui à
anouk qui était maquilleuse il ya
guillaume qui joue le rôle du buteur il
ya benoît qui est là pour plein de
choses en fait il a trahi son et puis
nous a aidés dans la direction
artistique
on va vous montrer un petit peu des
extraits de ce tournage et on espère que
ça vous plaira et que ce format ce
nouveau format vous plaira beaucoup aux
6 puis je vous en reparle est un petit
peu après rappelle les films de mariage
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas faire
beaucoup ici
[Musique]
enfin moi je suis la maquilleuse et puis
là pour occuper de françois ou en lice
pour le premier épisode et ça se passe
très bien j'avais déjà vous avec
françois donc super content de le
retrouver à nouveau
ouais ils prennent beaucoup de plaisir
peut-être même un petit peu trouve le
maquillage notamment pour la scène
d'aujourd'hui ça permet vraiment d'avoir
quelque chose de réaliste de cohérent et
et voila voila ok tu apprends moi
je constituerai que le boîtier
françois c'est toi le méchant de
trucs là tu as une tête de méchant
encore un problème est un problème c'est
tout nouveau pour nous quoi mais on se
marre donc à partir de là si on s'amuse
c'est peut-être déjà un peu gagné qu'est
ce qu'on pense tu prends de tu prends du
plaisir en fait moi je prends beaucoup
de plaisir ce campus est vraiment ces
gens là première fois que je fais ça sur
tout un tout une série avec des épisodes
des dialogues écrits et un rô le
important on va dire et c'est cool puis
françois qui a qui découvre aussi ça on
découvre au 500 en fait c'est super ce
un bon pour la fin
on va peut-être penser à changer de slip
mais sinon non non c'est cool
vivement les prochains épisodes je
connais ta petite chaîne youtube par
coeur la bien du plein format
vois pas ce que ça vu le nom de
mobylettes qui passe au score
non non non pas du tout pardon qui ont
été réalisés avec des supers 35 il faut
que ça aille vite sinon ça c'est le truc
qui s'éternise après ça ça fait quatre
ans j'en ai pour moi ça c'est le
perchiste
c'est ça ouais j'aime bien là perché sur
la perchiste renaud lavillénie
quand en plus menaçants jusqu'à ce que
clément qui compte vraiment qui est le
moment où on te voit avancer vers lui
fallut près possible de sa gueule
vraiment aller nous faut que je me lève
toi tu vas le plus proche de sa gueule
et le pain et tu penses et tu penses
mais il faut vraiment que en fait lui
lui joue ça soit il le du coup ils te
guide presque lui il est là il est en
train d'expliquer un truc mais tout d'un
coup ils te voit dans les yeux et
commence doucement à être là dans le
truc est en fait plus il ce recul et il
faut jamais que toi tu perds de la
distance tu vois franchement si
t'arrives par la compagne son site
d'arrivée en restant dans le champ à
finir là c'est génial c'est là qu'il va
se passer un truc bateaux qui valent
menacé en fait est un peu plus cher et
ce dont tu peux le suc et comment se
passe ce tournage en fait le tournage se
passe bien se passe bien parce que au
départ c'était un projet ambitieux je
crois que c'est la première fois qu'on
fait tout ça et j'ai l'impression qu'on
arrive à être à peu près crédible
c'est un peu de boulot mais en tout cas
le rendu à être au rendez-vous j'en suis
sûr est ce qu'un point de vue personnel
tu prends du plaisir
cette journée sinon je serais pas là
c'est beaucoup de plaisir avant tout
c'est la base de tout soupire bon super
est ce que tu veux ajouter quelque chose
bien non j'ai bien mangé
très bien mais qui était pas du tout
écrit comme ça c'est le côté j'ai
l'impression de revoir ma mère au café
que ses copines mais ça marche super
bien
sylvie l'acquitté jose mais qu'elle est
totalement ou noyées dans leurs maisons
va brasser restant jaillir sépare de ses
pas il le sait pas non ça va aider ces
facteurs va vouloir dire
il a totalement et a quand même envie
qui t'expliquent donc quand ça commence
à s'intéresser
évidemment tu es que tu as des petits
des titres chutent de nîmes au collège
déchire tout à fait une erreur mais
sympathique parfait hockey comme lui a
rechuté de moelle le capteur est annoncé
partant l'armée parce qu'il faut qu'ils
tiennent à vocal hockey est vraiment bon
alors à toi tu es qui te fait quoi sur
le tournage en chine mari et je suis
chef open de la mini-série de françois
troquer une bonne ambiance au tournage
les gens prennent du plaisir c'est
lorsqu'on ouais c'est top
pendant ce qu'on est tous donc non c'est
une super ambiance et
toujours un réel plaisir de bosser avec
eux c'est vraiment que le tournage s'est
passé avec quoi alors
on a choisi de tourner avec le nikon one
si cela n'apparait que j'aime vraiment
beaucoup
coucou maraine croyez-moi cocon du coup
niveau matos on est parti sur le z 6 2
avec la toon hausse puisqu'on a chanté
en corrèze euros on a tout enregistré
sur ce le disque dur pour pouvoir faire
un étalonnage sympa après n'a pas chuté
avec l'aed on a rajouté un filtre le
ciné blum de mon maître qui est donné un
petit look signer niveau optique on est
partis sur des optiques fixes on a
utilisé principalement le 50 et le 85
là on a fait le 35 aussi pour quelques
plans et puis voilà il a fait son effet
et c'est plutôt cool donc voilà on a
terminé le tournage on va partir au
montage on sait pas encore ce que ça va
donner donc va vous vous aurez déjà vu
en fait la vidéo au moment où vous voyez
cette vidéo c'est l'occasion aussi de
vous parler de ce nouveau format on va
essayer de sortir un épisode par mois
avec plein de petites vidéos qui seront
en rapport type making of
tout ça ça me rend vachement de temps il
faut vachement de monde et j'avais dit
il ya quelque temps qu'il y aurait plus
de vidéos sponsorisées sur la chaîne et
tout va ce que je cherche toujours le
cas j'ai pas envie de m'enrichir avec
des vidéos sponsorisées par contre buy a
une équipe qui a des gens et moi je suis
convaincu qu'il faut plier les gens
alors juste valeur donc ne vous
inquiétez pas si vous voyez quelques
sponsors passé par ci par là c'est pour
y danser les tracteurs qui passe à côté
oui merci tracteur s'est passé pour
financer en fait ce projet parce que du
coup c'est un gros projet nécessite
beaucoup de monde et donc voilà
d'ailleurs on remercie nikon qui a
sponsorisé ce making of
merci beaucoup me caunes n'hésitez pas à
dire dans les commentaires ce que vous
avez pensé de la fiction tout ça et de
ce nouveau format si ça vous a plu
pouvait lâcher le traditionnel coup deux
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui
situent juste pour cette vidéo vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait puis
surtout pour savoir la suite ce qui va
se passer dans les prochaines aventures
sur ce thème web série et puis moi je
vous dis à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo toi